There is a second notion of vector
multiplication that is common especially
in the context of engineering,
physics, and computer graphics.
This product is the cross product.
The cross product is very useful in
three dimensional linear algebra but
it does not have a generalization
to higher dimensions.
Geometrically, the cross product
of two vectors, v and w,
is a vector that is
orthogonal to both v and w.
And has magnitude of v times
magnitude of w times sine of
theta where theta is
the angle between v and w.
Note that unlike the dot product the
output of a cross product is a vector,
not a number.
Let's look at this definition
a bit more closely.
Notice that if theta is 0 or
pi that is 0 or
180 degrees, then the cross
product will have magnitude 0.
So in other words, the cross product of
two parallel vectors is the 0 vector.
Also if either v or
w is the 0 vector, then the cross
product will be the 0 vector as well.
Assuming we're not in one of these
degenerate cases, notice that there
were, in fact, two vectors that meet
the geometric description given so far.
These vectors are negatives
of each other.
In order to determine which vector to
use, we proceed by the right-hand rule.
Here's how the right-hand rule works.
If the cross product is v cross w,
imagine your right thumb pointing
in the direction of v and your right
index finger in the direction of w.
Then extend your right middle finger,
and
then the direction it points will
be the direction of the cross w.
So, in this case,
it will be pointing up.
Notice that if we switch the order
of the cross product to w cross v,
then using the right-hand rule will
give us the downward pointing vector.
This gives us the equation v cross
w equals the negative of w cross v
because switching the order of
multiplication negates the product.
We call the cross-product
anticommutative
as opposed to
the commutative dot product
in which switching the order
does not affect the product.
A consequence of this geometric formula
can be seen in the parallelogram
spanned by v and w.
Take the length of the v arrow to
be the base of the parallelogram.
Then the height of the parallelogram
is the length of this segment
from the head of the w arrow to the line
spanned by v perpendicular to v.
Using the trigonometric identity, sine
of theta equals opposite over hypotenuse
which is the SOH from SOH-cah-toa.
We have that sine of theta equals
the height divided by the length of w.
In other words,
the length of w times sine of theta
equals the height of the parallelogram.
Remembering that the area of
a parallelogram is base times height,
this means that the area of this
parallelogram is the magnitude of v
times the magnitude of
w times sine of theta.
In other words,
it's the length of v cross w.
Another geometric note is that the area
of this triangle spanned by v and
w is exactly one half of the area
of the full parallelogram.
That means the area of the triangle
will be one-half times
the magnitude of the cross product.
Again, all this is great, but
it's of little use to us without a
practical formula for the cross product.
So given vectors v with coordinates x1,
y1,z1,
and w with coordinates x2, y2,
z2, here's such a formula.
The cross product of v and
w is the vector.
First coordinate, y1z2- y2z1.
Second coordinate, it's the negative
of the quantity (x1z2- x2z1).
And the third coordinate is x1y2- x2y1.
So for an example, if we wanted to
find the cross product of the vectors,
v, which is 5, 3- 2, and w, which is- 1,
0, 3, then we would compute.
First coordinate, 3 x 3- 0 x -2.
Second coordinate, negative,
quantity of, 5 x 3- (-1) times (-2).
Third coordinate, 5 x 0- (-1) x 3.
And that would give us the vector 9,
-13, 3.
One way to help confirm that we did our
arithmetic correctly is by checking
that our outcome is orthogonal
to both of our vectors v and w.
The dot product of v with
the cross product will be
45- 39 + 6 = 0, and
then the dot product of
w with the cross product
will be -9 + 0 + 9 = 0.
So our result is orthogonal
to both v and w.
We can also use our cross product to
find the area of the parallelogram
spanned by v and w.
To do this we would take
the magnitude of our cross product,
which would be the square root of 9
squared + -13 squared + 3 squared.
Computing this gives us
approximately 16.093.